how are you we all love you tell us how
you are I am you know I'm okay
I'm keep going one foot in front of the
others I mean obviously you know this is
a difficult time I'm heartbroken but I'm
grateful to have my job and redress and
up out of the bed you and David released
your statement this week and you said on
Twitter that you two had grown apart how
did that happen
it's just life you know I'm sure you've
all you know witness a breakup you know
it's life work you know my held his job
the children can you know it's life is
the life is overwhelming for everybody
and it's a lot of work to you know to
keep it all together on the season we do
see the women question your illness how
did that make you feel you know what I
just let it roll over my back because I
have nothing to prove to anybody except
to myself to find a cure for a disease
that's been that I've been battling for
four years and so to be honest with you
it doesn't doesn't faze me I've heard it
for so many years now that it's you know
it goes in one ear out the other and I
just have a very laser-beam focus and
all I want to do is get to the finishing
line get my brain bag and teach the
world a lesson about Lyme disease and
that's my journey today